[Music]
this is like one of the most humbling
experiences of my life
Alex Rodriguez's romance with Jennifer
Lopez is a total grand slam but the
retired baseball pro revealed there's
been a challenge along the way he
revealed it on Thursdays Tonight Show
with Jimmy Fallon you know when I was at
the Yankees and we want to work
championship and you know you wear the
pinstripes you think you're pretty cool
but then you think I would Jennifer and
they confuse me with the security guard
all time I promise you we were at the
Met Ball and the paparazzi were
screaming at me not even in English get
the hell out of the way get out of the
way we're gonna take a picture
the couple is sharing their summer love
all over Instagram they traveled to
Paris and had a fun day by the pool with
J Lo's kids et recently spoke with both
stars they couldn't help but gush over
one another you know Jennifer's one the
most brilliant business mind I've ever
met she's the hardest working lady and
Jennifer is the role model he's so
supportive he's such a supportive person
and he's so lovely
[Music]
you